merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur bernard perrut ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
le 6 août 2015 était promulguée la loi
pour la croissance activité l'égalité
des chances appelée loi macro du nord du
ministre de l'économie une loi flav
avait de grandes ambitions et de petits
moyens et peu de résultats
dix-huit mois après les français ont-ils
l'impression que la croissance va mieux
non que l'activité économique va mieux
non que l'égalité des chances à mieux
non bien évidemment la croissance
elle atteint péniblement à 28 3% en 2015
et ne devrait pas être beaucoup plus
élevé en 2016
elle reste largement inférieur à la
croissance de la zone euro comme la
croissance mondiale l'activité
économique
c'est 1,1 million de chômeurs
supplémentaires depuis 2012
ce sont des hommes et des femmes qui
galère c'est l'effondrement des entrées
en apprentissage
alors un an et demi après le coup de
force du 49 3 pour passer outre votre
majorité divisée
que reste-t-il de la loi macron et bien
il reste la paille la pagaille dans
l'organisation territoriale des
professionnels du droit et le risque que
les premières victimes soient nos
territoires ruraux
il reste oui il reste la libéralisation
des autocars comme mesure phare
aujourd'hui aucune compagnie n'est
rentable
pire avec la faillite de la compagnie
bega bus de nombreux salariés ont perdu
leur emploi
tout ça pour ça monsieur le premier
ministre le président de la république
se représente pas
le premier ministre l'époque lui se
présente on ancien ministre de
l'économie qui avait fondu c'est un
droit c'est à vous que je demande
qu'elles sauront tirez-vous de la loi
macro qui ne règle aucun problème qui ne
contribue pas au redressement de la
france pour vous france avec le
gouvernement que vous représentez la
parole est à monsieur michel sapin
ministre de l'économie
et des finances merci monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les députés
monsieur le député peru sauf à ce que je
me trompe véritablement j'ai eu le
sentiment que votre question ne
s'adressait pas un membre de ce
gouvernement est que si vous voulez donc
adresser votre question à la bonne
personne fait le directement
je pense que nous sommes capables de
vous donner quelques coordonnées qui
vous permettront de poser vos questions
mais puisque vous épuisez polonais plaît
votre question portait sur la croissance
en france puisque votre question portait
sur la création d'emplois en france
puis je me permets de vous rappeler que
la croissance en france a repris en 2015
puis en 2016
elle s'est affirmée qu'elle a permis
monsieur le député
soyez honnête avec vous-même et avec
tout ce qui vous entoure de créer des
emplois en nombre comme jamais ils en
avaient été créés depuis 2008
depuis 2008 la croissance française la
réforme de l'économie française la
compétitivité des entreprises a permis
enfin enfin de faire reculer le chômage
ce n'est pas dire que tout va bien que
de dire qu'un certain nombre de choses
vont bien je pense qu'il serait de votre
devoir y compris en termes de
responsables français
presque par patriotisme de ne pas
toujours vouloir ravir la france quand
la france a aujourd'hui la capacité de
rebondir de créer des emplois et
d'investir nous étions il ya quelques
jours aux états unis
aux états unis on regarde la france je
ne parle pas de telle ou telle
personnalité
les acteurs économiques regarde la
france les investisseurs regardent la
france avec d'autres yeux que les vôtres
avec les yeux de ceux qui savent qu'ici
dans cette france on sait former des
ingénieurs que dans cette france
on s'est créé des entreprises que dans
cette france on sait relever les défis
et qu'on ne répond pas à des question
mesquine au répond aux principales faire
en sorte que la france sache réagir ça
se crée des emplois et sacré la
croissance